watching power Tommy you gotta go and  he's gotta be me  in anticipation of the upcoming season  five return of power 50 cents den of  thieves co-stars say they want in on the  hit star series  I need Gerard to make a guest appearance  get into the storyline we just himself  quite a few times I think it's about I  know exactly how many drinks take out  who everybody like they're gonna be  rematch I'm gonna give them a history  lesson as for whether Ghost and Kanan  will rekindle their friendship next  season 50 cent old et this suck you can  forgive people but you don't forget the  scenario so it's never really of a  full-on trust there between the two of  them again I think did they go to like  you see so many different changes in  actual I don't wanna blow it because I  want everybody still be excited today I  want to get the money  and get back a gold  [Music]